Dear Fellow Scholars this is Two Minute
papers with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
If we would like to see how digitally modeled
objects would look like in real life, we
would create a 3D model of the desired
scene, assign material models to the
objects within, and use a photorealistic
rendering algorithm to finish the job.
It simulates rays of light that connect
the camera to the light sources in the scene,
and compute the flow of energy between them.
Initially after a few rays we'll
only have a rough idea on how the image
should look like,
therefore our initial results will
contain a substantial amount of noise.
We can get rid of this by simulating the
paths of millions and millions of rays
that will eventually clean up our image.
This process: where a noisy image gets
clearer and clearer -- we call convergence,
and the problem is that this can take
excruciatingly long, even up to hours to
get a perfectly clear image.
With the simpler algorithms out there we
generate these light paths randomly.
This technique is called path tracing.
However, in the scene that you see here, most
random paths can't connect the camera and
the light source because this wall is in
the way -- obstructing many of them.
Light paths like these don't contribute
anything to our calculations and are
ultimately a waste of time and precious
resources. After generating hundreds of
random light paths we have found a path
that finally connects the camera with
the light source without any
obstructions. When generating the next
path it would be a crime not to use this
knowledge to our advantage. A technique
called "Metropolis Light Transport" will
make sure to use this valuable knowledge
and upon finding a bright light path it
will explore other paths that are nearby
to have the best shot at creating valid,
unobstructed connections. If we have a
difficult scene at hand
Metropolis Light Transport gives us way
better results than traditional,
completely random path sampling
techniques such as path tracing. Here are
some equal-time comparisons against path tracing
to show how big of a difference
this technique makes. An equal-time
comparison means that we save the output
of two algorithms that we ran for the
same amount of time on the same scene
and see which one performs better.
This scene is extremely difficult in the
sense that the only source of light is
coming from the upper left and after the
light goes through multiple glass spheres
most of the light paths that we
generate will be invalid. As you can see
the random path tracer yields really
dreadful results.
Well, if you can call a black image
a result that is. And as you can see
Metropolis Light Transport is extremely
useful in these cases.
And here's the beautiful, completely
cleaned up, converged result. The lead
author of this technique, Eric Veach, won
a technical Oscar Award for his work,
one of which was Metropolis Light Transport.
If you like the series please
click on that subscribe button to become
a Fellow Scholar.
Thanks for watching. There are millions
of videos out there and you decided to
take your time with this one. That is
amazing! Thank you and I'll see you next time!